good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we're going to start
with an obvious observation that's what
we specialize in it feels like this
country is losing control of inflation
it feels like it's getting worse
in dallas over the weekend a bottle of
water was going for eight dollars that's
water which we used to get for free from
the sky now eight bucks
and people are paying it too if you were
thirsty in downtown dallas on saturday
morning it didn't really have a choice
this is not a small development
inflation will make this country poor
and it will do it faster than anything
else will anyone who doesn't understand
that intuitively is an idiot or is
irresponsible or both
if you think covid or climate change or
police brutality or iran
is a bigger threat to the united states
and the devaluation of the us dollar
then you by definition should not be
making meaningful decisions you're a
[ __ ]
so with that standard in mind let's
check in with our friends over at cnn to
see what they're covering today on their
news channel oh it looks like they're
planning a palace coup at the white
house just another day in washington
turns out cnn's researchers have
discovered that joe biden is elderly and
unpopular breaking news and therefore
he's probably not the best vehicle for
the ambitions of the democratic party
going forward obviously biden isn't
going to serve two terms so as a public
service cnn has assembled a list of
people who should replace joe biden
it's all pretty amusing when you think
about it apparently somebody in cnn's
math department finally finished the
complicated calculations and concluded
that joe biden who's already had two
cerebral aneurysms will be 86 years old
by the end of his second term wait what
86 years old
cnn had no idea joe biden was that old
didn't tell us about it either clearly
this is not going to work time for
someone new
that's what they're saying
and honestly as you watch this you can
start to feel a little sad for joe biden
he's been in office less than a year and
already his own supporters are measuring
his coffin
but of course they are this was always
going to happen
professional democrats are not
sentimental people they're stony-hearted
realists joe biden has served his
biological purpose he stopped bernie
sanders in the primaries he made america
safe for private equity
carried interest is still in the tax
code mission accomplished so it's time
to pull joe biden off the stage before
he gets even older and less popular
that's what they're thinking it turns
out supporting joe biden was never about
any specific ideology we on the right
fell for that one but these people have
no interest in principles or ideas
loyalty is a foreign concept to them
they care only about power
it's kind of scary really
thankfully this same group is also
stupid
stupidity is their one redeeming quality
if they were smart they take over the
world they're certainly ruthless enough
but thank god they can't do that because
they're too limited by their own
bigotries and their tiny intellects
how dumb are these people
well they assume that everybody else is
just like them and that's always the
hallmark of true stupidity these are the
geniuses who believe salvador and
immigrants want to be called latinx
they can believe that because they don't
talk to salvador and immigrants they
only talk at them
so they have no idea that the average
salvadoran has social views that are so
terrifyingly right-wing they would be
banned on twitter instantly assuming
salvador and immigrants actually use
twitter which most of them don't because
they're smarter than cnn anchors
remember nancy pelosi was out there a
couple of years ago
talking about ms-13 when they were
terrorizing salvador and immigrant
communities and she was assuring us they
were little angels they're children of
god she said cena never sent a camera to
an actual salvadoran community
to ask what they thought of ms-13 the
people terrorized them what do you think
we do with ms-13 well cut them into
small pieces and feed them to the dogs
that would have been the answer didn't
see that on cnn
what's their views on the trans
community have to wonder do not put that
in the air either cnn hasn't even
thought about doing those interviews
because they assume they don't need to
the people seeing believe that everyone
who didn't vote for donald trump must
have the same opinions and concerns as
the average dingbat trusteefarian and
bozeman
they imagine a world populated entirely
by people like themselves
college-educated liberals with empty
personal lives and thank god they're
wrong
a world like that would be as sterile
and bossy and anti-human as the white
house press secretary imagine eight
billion gensakes
horrifying
but in reality
humanity is far more interesting and far
more yes diverse than that not that cnn
has caught on
nor do they have any idea how unpopular
they are
most americans are not racist no matter
what you might hear but an awful lot of
them secretly do hate the nasty uptight
self-righteous entitled white liberals
who run cnn and people like them if you
were to ask your average truck voter who
do you really dislike no not that anyone
would ever ask them that because nobody
cares what they think but if you were
they'd probably say to the cnn camera
crew actually
i'm not mad at black people i'm mad at
you
dislike of that group of people the
people of all the power in this country
is probably the deepest well of
prejudice in the united states and of
course it's totally justified does cena
know that no of course they have no idea
wait till you see their list of
replacements for joe biden each one is
tailor-made to appeal to the dingbat
trustefarian in bozeman and no one else
first on the list of course is kamala
harris and that makes sense she's the
vice president
the problem is nobody likes kamala
harris no one has ever liked kamala
harris from her earliest days on the
playground to her high school years in
canada to right now which is december 15
2021.
why is kamala hair so unpopular because
here's what she's like
and is that a socialist or progressive
perspective
no
the value of educators when they had
pregnant kids
[Applause]
it actually was mike pence on the debate
stage but
and said where is
apparently it left me like a block
behind i'd fallen out the stream
[Applause]
and i looked back up and i said freedom
[Laughter]
so kamala harris is a charmless phony
who has such total and utter contempt
for your intelligence that she fully
expects you to believe that her fake
life is real and that's bad but honestly
it's not necessarily a deal killer in
politics no one ever called richard
nixon charming
yet nixon won the biggest presidential
landslide in american history in 1972 so
what's the difference the difference is
richard nixon was competent he had
skills he could do things kamala harris
doesn't and she can't kamalaires is
totally incompetent she's zero skill
she's never done anything
harris can't redecorate her own office
she tried recently and she made it
uglier
so this isn't going to work we'll have
to take kamala harris off the list sorry
so how about pete buddha judge he's on
the list of course everyone at cnn loves
pete but a judge he's just like them
except a little spicier and much more
glib until a few years ago pete but a
judge dated women now he's openly gay
and a father and reads the atlantic
magazine and uses unintelligible buzz
words many many unintelligible buzz
words in fact unintelligible buzz words
are pete but a judge's entire vocabulary
you want to talk like pete but a judge
is not hard
take a phrase or issue any phrase or any
issue and add the word racism bingo you
have a promising future in the
democratic party
do you think that people who support
president trump and his immigration
policies are racist
anyone who supports this is supporting
racism our health care system is
burdened by racism we know that our
housing is burdened by racism our
schools are burdened by racism yes the
uniform is burdened by racism but it
goes far beyond that it is a matter of
concern for every american
that we dismantle systemic racism before
it ends the american project in our
lifetime
oh and rhodes are racist too
certain kinds of people love this if cnn
anchors could do science which of course
they can't but if they could pete but a
judge is the candidate they would create
in their basement lab road scholar
mckinsey consultant no actual
achievements of any kind people to judge
couldn't even run south bend indiana he
tried couldn't and that's not really
surprising but a judge has never shown
any interest in improving the lives of
actual people his only real skill is
talking about himself
every presidential election cycle you
see someone like this
democratic candidates who are in effect
media creations new york times pretends
they could actually get elected but no
every election cycle the voters laugh at
these people ask beto he's been there
so pete but a judge is off the list but
in his defense whatever but a judge's
fault at least he's not elizabeth warren
elizabeth warren is the candidate for
voters who find kamala harris too
authentic combo's just too real for me
i'd rather have the manufactured version
someone who pretends to be saying
american indian
so if that's you if that's what you're
looking for you're gonna love elizabeth
warren
here she is drinking beer with the man
she claims as her husband just like a
totally normal american totally normal
watch this hold on a sec i'm gonna get
me
um
a beer
hey
whatever my husband bruce is now in here
um
you want a beer i'll pass on the beer
for now i'm gonna pull this doodle and
sit down
i'm gonna get me a beer oh are you now
elizabeth warren maybe you will but not
in the white house that's not gonna fly
the truth is if you're going to replace
someone as old and familiar as joe biden
is you're going to need someone fresh
and new someone who's faults the country
isn't already very familiar with
maybe that's what cnn was thinking when
they included illinois governor jb
pritzker on the list
unfortunately even if you've never even
heard his name before jb pritzker's
faults are just too obvious to ignore
pritzker may be the only elected
democrat in america who is unhealthier
than joe biden a couple of years ago
pritzker broke his leg and then admitted
he had no idea how he did it he hasn't
seen his leg since 1993. now we're not
judging obviously but is this really the
president you need during a covid
pandemic jb pritzker is a walking
underlying condition plus and not
incidentally he has destroyed the state
of illinois
almost 13 million people live in
illinois though thanks to jb pritzker
there are far fewer them every day but
cnn did not bother to interview a single
one of them
so go ahead and wish jb pritzker the
best but don't count on seeing him in
the white house anytime soon but
if you're still fixated on replacing joe
biden with a governor cnn has a few more
ideas for you
cnn is recommending gretchen whitmer of
michigan and phil murphy of new jersey
now you read that
and you pause and you begin to suspect
that maybe this whole list is cnn's
stealthy attempt to test you to see what
you will believe how ludicrous can they
write it
phil murphy
phil murphy almost lost his job just
last month he was nearly defeated as an
incumbent democrat governor in a state
that has a million more democrats than
it has republicans
how much do people in new jersey hate
phil murphy that's how much they hate
him but now he should be president come
on
it feels like some pothead intern at cnn
just pulled up the wikipedia entry for
democratic governors and then copied
their names into the story that's got to
be what happened how else did gretchen
whitmer make the list come on now
you should also know that cnn recommends
a former mayor that would be mitch
landrieu of new orleans now you'll be
excited about this if you think joe
biden's hair plugs aren't quite absurd
enough
otherwise huh
actually mitch laner was a perfectly
nice guy it's charming and friendly
but the question is how's new orleans
doing these days
is it cleaner is it safer is it a better
place to live how are the schools
come on if you've been there you know on
the other hand if mitch landrieu is
going to make the list then why not bill
de blasio
why doesn't bill de blasio replace joe
biden he certainly has got the time to
do it he's unemployed
this could be bill de blasio's chance to
turn all of america into penn station
what a campaign slogan that would be de
blasio 2024 make america filthy again we
can't wait for cnn's endorsement of that
no doubt it's coming
so at this point we're getting toward
the bottom of cnn's biden replacement
list and that's where we find the name
of one stacey abrams abrams was once a
state representative in georgia now she
describes herself as a quote voting
rights activist whatever that is
electing stacey abrams president of the
united states would amount to the single
largest act of equity ever committed in
the modern era unfortunately would also
signal the end of the modern era you
know exactly the kind of country you
would get with stacey abrams in charge
is she unqualified for the job oh of
course she's unqualified
but she's also when this is an extra
bonus totally delusional
to this day
more than three years after the fact
abrams have never conceded that she lost
the georgia governor's race she still
claims that election was stolen from her
but wait a second you ask
isn't that an attack on democracy
when you challenge an election result in
this country you are as liz cheney often
tells us shredding democratic norms
you might as well be living in moscow at
that point because you my friend are
doing the bidding of vladimir putin
you're an insurrectionist
and yet
stacy abrams is not living in moscow
she's living in atlanta in pretty
luxurious circumstances actually all
made possible by the huge amounts of
cash she has raised fighting for quote
voting rights
a few years ago abrams spent nearly a
million and a half dollars on
residential real estate for herself
despite owing the internal revenue
service 54 thousand dollars in back
taxes now that is equity in action
so once again you know precisely who
stacey abrams is
but still
there is something about her that's not
quite as repulsive as the rest of the
people on cnn's list say what you will
about stacy abrams she's not synthetic
she's no pete buddha judge who was
clearly implanted with some kind of
neo-liberal master chip when he worked
at mckinsey must stop climate change now
no stacy abrams isn't really like that
she's a grifter obviously
but there is still a spark of
recognizable humanity within her she's
clearly got an active personal life
here's an excerpt from the softcore porn
novel she wrote called hidden sins
[Music]
their tongues tangled
danced and she reveled in the movement
she splayed eager palms against his
chest
and tormented the flesh she found there
too far away she gripped his waist to
pull him closer
until she stood cradled
between his hard thighs
that voiceover comes from our highly
talented producer mr alex mccaskill but
imagine stacy abrams doing the same
thing
imagine stacy abrams standing on the
west front of the capitol building three
years from now at her inauguration
reading her own words from hidden sins
as she faces the slender but rigid
washington monument
somehow strange as it sounds we can
imagine that in fact we can imagine it
vividly cnn would be thrilled by the
whole thing and we know for certain that
jeff toobin would cover it
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis